we have breaking news from london for
you now where british prime minister
boris johnson faces a challenge from his
own party today that could force him out
of office
it's called the no confidence vote it
follows a series of scandals raymie
inocencio is in london now with more on
that story remia we saw the prime
minister get booed very loudly at the
queen's jubilee celebration over the
weekend it'll be interesting to see the
outcome of this vote today good morning
to you
and good morning to you gail but not a
good day for uk prime minister boris
johnson that is after
what appears to be a
big pushback against at least 15 percent
of the members of his own party his
conservative party who have now
submitted letters saying that they don't
have confidence in their own prime
minister that is at least 54 members of
parliament now the source of this
frustration comes from what's so called
the party gate scandal these leaked
photos you're seeing now show him and
members of his staff holding booze
filled social gatherings during the
country's coveted lockdowns critics say
that that was not only hypocritical but
also illegal and that led to a police
probe where johnson himself was fined
high inflation too like in the u.s is
also turning people against johnson
and as you mentioned gail that anger was
on display this past weekend that was
where johnson was publicly booed outside
of saint paul's cathedral before a
special service
for the queen's 70th platinum jubilee
now the vote of confidence kicks off in
just about six hours time but if passed
his precedent then history is not on
johnson's side for example his
predecessor theresa may did survive her
own vote of no confidence but then she
had to resign just six months after that
and back in 1990 then prime minister uh
uh margaret thatcher excuse me survived
her own vote of no confidence but then
she resigned just eight days later nate
raymien ausencio and london thank you